NOW BACK TO "HANNITY."
♪ ♪
>> Sean: AS WE CONTINUE WITH
OUR ANGEL PARENTS, ALL HAVING
LOST A LOVED ONES, TO THEIR
CHILDREN, TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
WE ONLY HAVE 5 MINUTES LEFT.
I WANT TO RUN THROUGH --
OBVIOUSLY A BIG NATIONAL,
POLITICAL DEBATE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THIS
MANUFACTURED CRISIS?
WHAT WORDS DO YOU WANT TO SAY TO
THE PRESIDENT, NANCY, CHUCK,
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE NANCY
AND CHUCK SCHUMER TO MY SON'S
GRAVE ON JANUARY 28TH SO THEY
CAN CELEBRATE -- NOT
CELEBRATE -- CRY WITH ME AS HIS
GRAVE, HIS MANUFACTURED GRAVE.
THIS IS PERMANENT FAMILY
SEPARATION.
>> Sean: PERMANENT FAMILY
>> LIKE MY SHIRT SAYS.
WHAT SEPARATES ME AND MY SON IS
NOT A FENCE, IT IS 6 FEET OF
DIRT AND A COUGH AND GET HOW
DARE SHE.
>> Sean: HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE
MET THE PRESIDENT?
ALL OF YOU HAVE.
I REMEMBER WE DID A SHOW IN THE
CAMPAIGN -- I GOT EMOTIONAL ON
THAT SHOW.
I'M SURE YOU WILL AT SOME POINT,
TOO, WATCHING THE PRESIDENT
FIGHT, YOU HEAR THE MANUFACTURED
CRISIS, WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SAY
TO THEM?
STEVE?
>> CHUCK SCHUMER AND
NANCY PELOSI ARE JUST
HYPOCRITES.
I'M BEING FLAT-OUT HONEST, IT IS
HYPOCRITE.
YOU, YOURSELF, HAVE SHOWN VIDEO
CLIPS OF NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER TELLING PEOPLE WE
NEED THIS WALL, WE NEED TO STOP
STOP --
>> Sean: THAT IS WHEN OBAMA
WAS PRESIDENT.
>> SO WHAT CHANGE?
JUST VOTES, GLOBAL ECONOMY?
THEY ARE HYPOCRITES.
IT IS DISGUSTING.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU SAY >>
NANCY PELOSI IS A DINGBAT.
ONE WEEK SHE WANTS THE WALL,
NEXT WEEK SHE DOESN'T, ONE-TENTH
OF 1% OF MONEY --
>> Sean: ONE-TENTH OF 1% OF
THE BUDGET.
>> SHE WANT TO GIVE IT.
IT IS ABSURD.
I THINK BLOOD IS ON HER HANDS.
SHE ABSOLUTELY TOOK AN OATH TO
PROTECT AMERICAN CITIZENS.
SHE IS NOT DOING IT, SHE DOESN'T
EVEN WANT TO TRY JUST BECAUSE
SHE HATES THIS BEFORE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS WRONG WITH
HER.
>> Sean: ARE YOU HAPPY THE
PRESIDENT IS HOLDING THE LINE?
>> I'M VERY HAPPY.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE, I WOULD
LOVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO STAND IN
FRONT OF NANCY PELOSI, MOTHER TO
MOTHER, AND LOOK HER IN THE EYE,
AND SAY WHICH CHILD OR
GRANDCHILD OF YOUR YOURS WOULD
YOU GIVE UP TO SUPPORT THE AGEND
YOU GIVE UP TO SUPPORT THE AGEN,
THIS HORRENDOUS LIE, THE
DESECRATION OF OUR CHILDREN, OUR
LOVED ONES LIVES, IT IS LIKE A
SLAP IN OUR FACE AND A CHIP TO
OUR LOVED ONES BRAINS EVERY TIME
SHE DOES THAT GET I WANT THE
PUBLIC TO KNOW AND NANCY PELOSI
TO KNOW, I CALLED HER OFFICE
AGAIN TODAY AND REQUESTED
ANOTHER MEETING NEXT WEEK WHEN I
AM IN D.C.
DEAD SILENCE FROM HER STAFFER.
I SAID THIS IS ANGEL MOM
MARIANNE MENDOZA, MEET
FACE-TO-FACE, MOTHER TO MOTHER
WITH NANCY PELOSI ABOUT THIS
SITUATION.
DEAD SILENCE, AND HE STAFFER
SAID NO.
I WILL PUT YOU THROUGH, YOU CAN
LEAVE A VOICE MAIL.
THIS IS HOW NANCY PELOSI --
>> I DID ASK HER THAT VERY
QUESTION.
I TOLD HER WHAT HAPPENED TO
JOSH, AND I SAID WHICH CHILD
COULD YOU SACRIFICE FOR THIS?
SHE JUST GLAZED OVER, WE ARE
PRAYING FOR YOU, I JUST NEED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT EVERY PERSON
IN OUR CENTURY         SANCTUARY
IN OUR CENTURY         SANCTUARC
IN OUR CENTURY         SANCTUARS
IN OUR CENTURY         SANCTUARA
LAW-ABIDING CITIZEN.
>> Sean: THE MEDIA ECHOES THE
EXACT WORDS OF WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE SAYING,
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
I'M SURE YOU ALL WATCH TV.
HOPEFULLY YOU DON'T WATCH FAKE
NEWS.
>> NANCY PELOSI, I HAVE MY ONLY
CHILD ASHES IN THIS URN, I CARRY
HIS ASHES IN A LITTLE LOCKET.
THIS IS THE LAST TIME I GOT TO
TOUCH MY CHILD.
THOSE ARE HIS BRUISED, COLD,
DEAD HANDS, WITH ME TOUCHING HIM
AND KISSING HIM THE LAST TIME.
AND SHE DOESN'T JUST HAVE BLOOD
ON HER HANDS, SHE NEEDS BOOTS
BECAUSE THAT BLOOD IS RISING,
SHE IS KNEE-DEEP IN IT.
IF SHE DOESN'T GET WITH THE
PRESIDENT TO ENTER THIS, SHE IS
GOING TO NEED BOOTS ALL THE WAY
UP TO HER THIGH BECAUSE IT IS
GETTING WORSE.
>> Sean: ARE YOU ANGRY WITH
THE MEDIA?
[GENERAL AGREEMENT NOISES]
>> Sean: I THOUGHT LIBERALS
WERE SO COMPASSIONATE.
[CROSS TALKING]
>> THIS IS PREVENTABLE.
THIS IS PREVENTABLE IN OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Sean: HE SANCTUARY CITY,
STATE ISSUE, CRIMINAL ALIENS,
NOT JUST PEOPLE THAT CAME HERE
TO WANT A BETTER LIFE, IN JAIL,
THEY LET THEM GO, BASICALLY
ASSIST THEM OUT THE DOOR SO
THEY DON'T GET DEPORTED?
>> THE ONLY ONE IN THIS GROUP
THAT GOT JUSTICE THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL COURT SYSTEM FOR
JOSHUA, I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
ELSE HAS DONE THAT.
THANK YOU, TEXAS, FOR THAT.
IT DOES HAVE SOME SORT OF --
THERE FOR A LONG TIME.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY ELSE GOT
JUSTICE.
>> Sean: WE ARE GOING TO END
OF THIS HERE.
I WANT TO PERSONALLY COME
OVER -- THANK YOU.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE, I'M SORRY SO
MUCH.
YOU ARE SO STRONG, I HOPE YOU
GET THAT MEETING.
MY DAUGHTER IS SO BEAUTIFUL,
REALLY.
AND YOUR SON, THE SAME.
>> THANK YOU.
THIS IS NOT TRUMP'S WALL, THIS
IS AMERICA'S WALL.
>> Sean: WE CAN HAVE A DOOR,
TOO.
WE JUST WANT TO BET YOU.
STEVE, THANK YOU.
YOUR SON, GRANT, MAYS ANCHORED
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I KNOW THIS IS THE HARDEST TIME
FOR BOTH OF YOU, THIS JUST
HAPPENED THE 29TH OF DECEMBER.
THANK YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
STORY, I HOPE AMERICA HEARS.
MORE SPECIFICALLY, I HOPE THE